as a kid from the streets of compton
california
overcome poverty racism police brutality
inadequate access to healthcare
resources
and go on to go to harvard caltech and
then become a full professor of
neurobiology
at one of the top universities in the
world overcoming all that
and then going further in a mission as
if that wasn't enough
today's guest professor gentry patrick
is going to tell you
exactly how he did it gentry
my friend my relative
it's so great to have you here uh it's
so great to have you here um
into the impossible podcast it's always
fun to have brilliant guests on the
podcast
but it's even more fun when it's a dear
friend and an innovative intellect like
yourself so thank you very much
thank you yeah thank you so much i
thought we'd begin
as a little teaser i kind of see you as
this you know as this action superhero
came out of you know some of the some of
the most challenging shall we say the
euphemism
uh locations of the world to become
essentially the top of your game and a
lot of
the things that we do on the into the
impossible podcast is talk to
the highest achievers that are have
achieved the greatest heights in their
professions and
you are one of them thank you for
including me yeah
it's true it's like i feel like i'm the
you know the drummer is what you call
the guy who hangs out with musicians
i got to hang out with professors so
first of all what's your background
what the heck is neurobiology and how
did you get out of compton you know
which is not
usually considered you know one of the
one of the safest places in the world to
grow up
uh overcoming all those challenges that
i mentioned how did you get to where we
are today
all right yeah i mean that's a lot there
let me see if i can do it succinctly
and um give you some of the saline
aspects that really drove
my trajectory to where i am today uh i
grew up
in south central l.a as as you just
mentioned
um compton california my mom had 16
years old
uh so there are definitely a lot of
challenges in my life for sure
but um you know i was curious kid
there are a lot of kids just like me who
were very interested in
doing well in school but you know
there's a lot of
serendipity and a lot of luck and so
what really needed to happen for me was
getting on a path where i was able to
um take advantage of my interest
in science i think part of myself being
a kind of a nerd
definitely helped me think about where i
might want to go i didn't know that i
could be a scientist i didn't know
anything about neurobiology
um this was not a part of any
experience anyone in my uh family had
had ever
um so even though i had lots of
challenges and we can talk about some of
the details there
you know brian compton is definitely
challenges of
gangs and drugs and lack of
adequate you know education but
you know i did have a family i did have
people who cared about me i had teachers
that
saw my potential and little um
sparks and little moments of mentorship
uh would push me kind of guide me in the
right direction as i
you know went on my own path um
interestingly enough uh you know
serendipity and love plays
like i said played a lot of uh
a big role in my life for instance when
it was time to go to college
this is a very funny story and i would
never tell anyone to do this
you know your kids are applying to
college i forgot that you had to
pay for applications to go to college
which so happened that
when i was ready to apply to college i
had enough money to play for one school
which is not the way to do it that's a
sure better way to
uh maybe go to junior college first
which in this
world today right now is such a bad idea
yeah exactly but uh
luckily i got into the one school i
applied to and i was berkeley and they
took me
and so thank you to all those people on
the admissions committee
that took me in um because i don't know
where my life would be
if i had not started on that path now
getting to berkeley
it was tough you know it was very tough
i actually had to
transition from a place where i kind of
understood
how to negotiate navigate and interact
with people i'm a people person so that
you know that was gonna keep developing
but you know i got there was challenging
on the first two years i didn't do
very well in school but really getting
access to a lab
um here's another funny serendipitous
and kind of luck
story but you know luck is one thing but
taking advantage of the luck that is
presented to you is another thing right
[Music]
right so um i was working for
the employment development department
that probably would
mean something to a lot of people right
now that's right uh it was a little
summer just more relevant than ever
i had a little summer job and um what
happened was
my job was to give uh
summer jobs to young people for the
summer
that's been you know interview them and
match them what happened was that
a job came through dishwashing for a
local
company a biotech company in in um
in bay area and i sent myself on that
job and i got it
i knew i had to get in somewhere and
that really was the beginning having
stability having a job a permanent job
and taking the initiative to take an
initiative to do that
literally sending myself on that
interview and i got the job
and um from there i was able to you know
have some stability
um gain a little bit more about my
self-identity
in stem i really didn't know that i was
gonna go to grad school i was very
interested in medicine yeah
um eventually i graduated we got
wait-listed
everywhere in med school and so what i
did
was this two years program at
ucsf university of california san
francisco which was called the research
training program at that time
took two minority students a year very
competitive to get in and i got in and
from there is really you know
i was i was on a path i was speeding
down the road
to where i am now with a lot of bumps
there wasn't an unimpeded lane that i
had
but some of the most important parts of
my time
was my advisors um so they made a big
impact in my life i had three um
very at the time young women scientists
who were
powerhouses in the field they were in um
aaron o'shea who's now the president of
howard hughes
leeway tsai who's a phenomenal
neuroscientist
then at harvard where i went to grad
school and now is the director of the
pick ralph center at
mit and uh aaron schuman
um who was at cal tech where i did my
postdoc and
that's where we crossed that's right
yeah and a mutual friend cameron diba
yeah and uh was able to and
then she moved to frankfort germany
max point director they were all hhmi
investigators they all promoted me they
were not just mentors they were amazing
advocates um and so
it's just this twist and turns of
access and advocacy and mentorship
but also um what i realized and why
you know that statement that you started
this with
is really important because you have a
lot of kids who have the potential
they're super smart they're maybe coming
from
underserved populations but they have
the goods to get it done
and they have an interest in their own
well-being and their families well-being
but it does have to be paired with um
access and mentorship and
advocacy you could not go into
a community and
uh give a talk you know at an assembly
say in a junior
middle school or high school or
elementary school and
expect that a kid seen you once
and says that one moment in time where i
met professor keating
is going to drive me all the way to
become a professor in astrophysics
i would say you would need a few more
moments
especially with me especially with not
just with you but
that that individual needs to be able to
you know consistently consistently and
so what happens a lot of kids they come
to college
but they're you know they're working and
you know
uh we need to really kind of think about
what
leveling the playing field really looks
like does it mean we're
choosing someone over another no we're
actually
making sure that the potential that is
in an individual
is really comes out and shines that's
all that is right
and so that was my life and uh when i
got to ucsd
i was surprised if someone gave me a job
so i took it me too
don't tell our boss don't tell a lot of
dogs yeah exactly
can i find a replacement been here 16
years
well i think i'm on my 10th phd student
i had post docs
um some of my you know they landed all
different places whether they'd be in
faculty members it's amazing i can't
believe
now as a full professor my trajectory
and i'm very humbled i'm humbled by my
experience i'm humbled by the fact that
individuals have wanted to spend their
time with me
grad student wants to spend five six
years with me well
there's a mutual that's right it's a
relationship
um but you know uh i
i'm very pleased that um
the time that i've had here and what
i've been able to do
as a scientist as a neuroscientist very
funny story um
again serendipity i'm sorry if this is
jumping all over the place but uh my fir
i did a masters with aaron o'shea
she taught me what hard work was so and
i'm sure she
she would agree uh she taught me what
hard work was
um and i was working on a kindness
called 485
and yeast what's a kinase it's a enzyme
that attaches phosphate
onto other molecules whether taking it
from
you know typically atp and attaching it
to
another molecule which can change its
structure and therefore its function
um and so and typically they are
involved in cell signaling
whether that is involved in responses to
stress
or different metabolic states or in
in the case of neurons a variety of
activity dependent things that are
involved in things like learning and
memory
as well as when synapses are
dysfunctional things like
alzheimer's and other neurogenic
diseases that
alter a synapse function
and mental states and ability to
function properly
um so what's funny is that i was working
on a kinase in her lab and when i got to
harvard
i worked on another kinase called cdk5
it just so happened to be the functional
homologue
uh so in yeast and then i was working on
the same kinase
so to speak it doesn't say mammals right
okay
um i remember another
funny it's not it's not hilarious yet
but uh but i know you're getting there
i'm sure you're gonna get to the biology
part that makes it stand up to stand up
yeah i mean to me that was when i string
it together when i look back
okay so it might not be that it's
serendipitous again it is certainly
there's a huge role in your life i've
i've noticed that about you
but the thing that's so uh noteworthy
about you start interrupting it
is is that you you take advantage of the
serendipity it's like
you know they say luck is when the
prepared mind meets opportunity
and you a lot of people might just be
like okay well that's interesting but
you were like
let me latch on to that like a kinase on
a protein
and let me take full advantage of it and
a lot of people wouldn't i don't know if
i would
yeah you know i think
that was learning how to
relinquish my fear and not
not hold myself back by
giving to the fear fear was always there
right
i didn't know i could trust people i
walk into a room in a scientist as a
neurobiologist i'm
probably the only black person in the
room but i didn't lean in with fear i
kind of came in
thinking that what brought us together
was the science i knew there were a lot
of challenges and issues
for instance there's an issue when you
don't see other faculty of color
at an institution in neuroscience or
graduate students in undergrads
and we need to change that the only way
we're going to change that is to be a
part of the solution
um and for me which is a good
point um over the last four or five
years i've really thought a lot about
that
um in the division of biological
sciences i'm also the director of
nutrition and diversity
i also served as the associate director
of the neuroscience graduate program
but in my diversity role um and i've
always had to wear two hats
uh run a lab and i've also been very
interested i'm gonna ask you about that
diversity
um and for me it has to be exist on the
same page right
academic excellence and diversity cannot
be divergent they have to be seen as two
things that go handy right and so
by being successful i've had a platform
right
um and my success again i'm humble
because i know that it's
due to the hard work that people in my
lab and we did together
um but you know
that has allowed me to lend my voice to
problems that need to be solved and that
is indeed
um when we need to
do better that's probably the easiest
way to do it do better
and make sure that kids from the inner
city are learning that stem
can be for them it's all around them in
their world
right right um they're naturally curious
they're naturally curious about it you
have to like work to
make them and they can contribute to
this also right uh
and and take advantage of um the joys of
actually being involved in stem
and there's a variety of things that you
can do in stem of course as
you know um and so i started a
scholarship program
and how did i do that i did that through
um a serendipitous walk
right i got on a plane and went across
the country multiple times talking to
people
about my life i share my story and they
find they
find points where they hey maybe you
might want to think about this
and eventually things stop and i
realized what i wanted to do was create
a program
that would basically
initially i used to say i wanted to
rival nepotism
we can we can set that to the side for
now that is provocative
and then uh and then come back
but indeed what if you gave kids from
the inner city
underserved populations all access
mentors
experiences research experiences
adequate finances so that they didn't
have to work uh
people that helped work on their
self-identity right
can be prescriptive it has to be
something where they're buying in
wholeheartedly and you want those types
of individuals that's why you do
the type of science you do right because
you you feel it in your bones it's a
part of you
um your identity yeah i i love
sharing that passion that i have in
neuroscience right
and when you look at it just want to go
back to what you said before you know
you're doing this
uh you know you're full professor you're
running programs and on top of that
which i barely have enough time to do
what i do
it seems to me unfairly or not that you
and and other minority professors that
were blessed to have his colleagues here
you know they have an extra tax it's
basically you get called upon not only
to solve the problems
of of your scientific field which is
what you're trained in
but also solve a larger societal problem
at large which is
how do we increase representation and
you know to first approximation
if you want someone to solve those
problems you know don't come consult a
cosmologist you know it's not
in my wheelhouse but i have friends you
know my friend professor stefan
alexander
president national society of black
physicists he's also always involved jim
gates president of aps elect
yeah it seems like it seems like all of
you guys that are my friends
you you guys are super human and you
have this pretty natural ability to do
stuff
but honestly between us and you know
thousands of people that are going to
watch this is this a burden
that that african americans especially
have to have to shoulder that
maybe it's not fair and and is there a
better way you know for allies for
whatever
other people whatever you want to call
people like me to step up and and really
do a part so that you can also focus on
the thing that god or whoever you want
to put you on earth to do which is your
science
in addition to the to the right to the
mentorship that you right right
um uh to be frankie it is
unfair right and you wonder why we do it
and you you look when you look at the
people doing it right the gym gates
the uh your friends uh
myself and others it's like this people
are
pretty significantly you know they've
done very well in their career
but then they they realized like i could
take this and leverage it to make change
yeah
um i think you you hit on something
right and
and i think it's important in this time
right now when we think about racism and
the social unrest
that is happening where um it's not
really a
moment or a movement this is like an
awakening that
we're having and hopefully more and more
people have that awakening where
they realize that they can contribute
whether that's a small amount or a large
amount
first thing is really acknowledging the
problem and the problem is
that there are inadequacies there are
systematic um things in place that
really prevent people
if we're going to say specifically in
stem underserved and
uh underrepresented minority students
keeps them from actually having the
access and going down this path and we
need to
change that um i have been inundated
thank you to all my colleagues who
reached out sorry if i can't
uh reply to all your emails i i really
am
thankful that you've reached out to me
um they know that where my heart is and
what
the passion that i have to do this work
while also running my lab
um so there needs to be resources um
and there needs to be allies and i'm
glad that uh other faculty are stepping
up faculty who aren't black and brown
are stepping up uh in ways to really
contribute
and show their um
kind of just leaning in to to deal with
the problem
right i didn't have uh my none of my
mentors
were black or brown you know white
and asian but they
they cared about me and they cared about
where i could go
and the possibility of what my life
could be and by doing that they've been
impacted all the people that i've
impacted so leveraged right
so that's real leveraging right and i
think if we
think about this uh in a simple way like
that
you know it's it's how do you affect
change one person at a time mm-hmm
right and then there's a lot of us yeah
right
and then the question is yeah how do you
get that lever and get maximum
mechanical advantage
right move the world literally as our
communities would say
uh so the question i guess next that i'm
interested in
is how much of this is nature for you
versus nurture
for you so you were a curious kid what
was what was the eight-year-old gentry
like
uh because i know you if i had to say
like what are you
in addition to like scientists so like
you and i have this income
we're scientists like you do something i
can't comprehend i always say you know
don't talk to me about what gentry does
it's brain science i just do rocket
science you know
uh but uh but with you i see you as
another
modality of your persona is mentor
slash um a leader and then the other one
is kind of like
father but it doesn't just mean of your
children and i feel like that's how we
resonate as well
uh we have biological children but we
also have ideological children and i
guess my question for you is
what part of that comes from the
eight-year-old gentry you know some kid
out there watching this 12 year old
gentry
i know that age was very formative for
me to become an astronomer i was
actually getting into astronomy at that
age
what's your scientific world line the
path that got you here
and how much of it was was nature just
the way that whoever made you you want
to say or
how you were you know uh you programmed
genetically versus how you were brought
up
right uh all the way up through your
your schooling okay
so great question great question
um no one knows an eight-year-old as an
eight-year-old
that they're going to become a professor
at a top-tier university
there's a product so
and even if you predicted that this
person might be in the place
to have the luck to do you you just
don't know
no one knows that they're going to show
up here and do well so
um it really is the experience that you
have
your ability to deal with failure though
you played a big part in my life
right um but
also i think what was really important
as a grad student was my ability just to
get in the lab
and just love my science just like you
know
it i still have the other pressures and
things that have
to do with my life with regards to you
know maybe being the only black
graduate student or what have you but i
i i owned my science and it was
it was something that i contributed to
um
and that kept me going yeah um but when
you really think about
you know how do you get all these steps
to where you are now
you know it's being in a place to take
advantage of
you know not being afraid to say okay
i'll go to this place i'll take this job
it may be really really tough and
competitive but i'll i'll go for it
right yeah
and uh i think we all have competitive
nature and um
spirit but we but for me
i learned to begin to have empathy
for myself and that spilled out
into the realm of the interactions that
i had and for having empathy for others
and you may say what is that what does
empathy have to do with your science
trajectory but it does have a lot to do
it because
i um i learned how to
uh uh really leverage that empathy
to to keep getting up every day or else
i would have you know there's a lot of
people with leads you say
okay 16 years gentry and they haven't
hired another neuroscientist before you
know
like but but things will change yeah and
things are changing
and persistence i guess i'm i'm always
the hopeful one
i'm not you know there probably are
others who might be a little bit more
critical of the system and
i'm definitely can find the faults of
where
where we are even at ucsd and across the
country
but i have hope for a better day you
know
i don't look at my kids and say wow my
kids are just
gonna have to deal with this crazy world
that we live in
i'm gonna try to make it better yeah
right and so
that's what drives me yeah i see you as
this you know relentlessly curious
incredibly passionate upbeat cheerful
and yeah you're a realist you're not
just a pure starry-eyed optimist you
know you're like there are problems in
society there's systemic problems
but then you know the system is also
made up of individuals and you look for
the good and the individuals
and you work to educate them in ways
that they might not be aware they might
have blind spots
yeah right yeah yeah that's is a good
point i was
i want to make sure i bring up something
for me
um the power of partnerships
and the power of storytelling will drive
the innovative change that we need
not only in our
science but definitely in the realm of
providing access
mentorship and advocacy for those uh
coming from underserved populations yeah
that is what we need and
so when you are able to tell your story
right
you know some kid becomes a a financier
or wall street banker not because he
just walks in and they
say check these boxes now they learn
right they they follow someone around
they
they so in turn our stories drive the
next generation and we're helping these
young kids build their own stories and
so that
for me is if you ask anyone um that that
knows me
well that's what drives me right i think
if you could only learn from people that
look exactly like you
it's going to be hard to make a lot of
progress because we can't learn all the
lessons of people that lived
you know in in the middle east in the
1400s
you just can't like say um that doesn't
look like me so i can't do it on the
other hand
you do need to see the 200 people like
you absolutely
and i and i see that you know you see
the famous president president obama and
he's meeting with a young
african-american kid and the kid asks
can i touch your hair
and it's like one of the most iconic
pictures of his presidency because he's
like this kid is physically embodying
that he could someday be president as an
african-american blind it's just like
giving me shutters there
that's a very possible speaking of
watching i remember
as a kid and this is like a junior
senior in high school
about to roll out with my cousins and
friends
and they were like gentry you can't go
with this tonight
because we might get into something that
you know i mean some something had
happened and they were like
there was some tension and attention
back in compton back then was
not just we're gonna sit down we're
gonna have a conversation
right and so i had i mean this is very
salient moment in my
memory for me ginger you can't go with
this because
you're the smart one or you're the one
that cares about all this science stuff
we can't have you get caught up in there
protecting you
so i have cousins and friends
some of which who you know may be caught
up in the penal system
that looked out for me
spared me the catching if i had caught a
case as they call it
right i might not be here right
take me back yeah you're uh in the in
the uh
seventies eighties and in compton
growing up
you're curious kid nerdy definitely
nerdy and so you got the nerd
gene genetically because your parents
weren't scientists right uh
but you know what was the environment
like what was the kind of milieu that
you were involved with
that gave you the work ethic and the
integrity what
what was that well as a young child
um i you know my mom had me at 16 and i
was living with my mom
for many years before i moved with my
dad and actually my mom passed away
quite young at 37 37 38 years old and
one of the things she instilled in me
was
just my love of education
or my will to be
you know to get great uh great grades to
do well in school
to put myself in the best position and
to move forward and use as an
education as a means to uh
whether you want to in some cases say a
way out
or to leverage it to do something better
with my life and then
in this case when you look now i'm full
circle circling back
to kind of feedback on the system and
impact others
um and so she would tell me you know you
got to be smarter than anyone else in
the room
uh and you know i love school and i
i worked hard and um i didn't have much
tv
i think i got like 30 minutes of tv a
day
i had to do workbooks all the time she
pushed me
but it's very interesting that a young
mother like that would push their kid
and i was our only child
to this to to do something great we both
had no idea where i would go
i could have gone straight to jail ten
years later but
you know i i didn't and i kept pushing
and um i really you know those are
some of the fond moments when i think
back what gave me my
strength and my grit and it was the it
was that
but you have this grip and it wasn't
like a chip on your shoulder or whatever
it's like there was no resemblance it
was like
you're going to maximize your vector
right and what you're doing and
then you're going to pull people up with
you right right um
at a very early age we talked a little
bit about empathy right yeah
i learned that
i learned that mentorship was really
important but i also learned
how i actually had mentors that did not
know they were my mentors
right i was always absorbing the world
around me
trying to uh reading books
uh interacting with people when people
would tell me
their stories i would jot things down
and i would be listening intently
because i was trying to figure out my
own playbook to do something successful
with my life
again no idea that i would be here in
this capacity
but um that's what i tell students now
i'm like
everyone in a position even someone that
you think is probably
contributing negatively to the space
around you
that you can still learn something from
that experience
experience even if it's just learning
about yourself and how you deal with
that yeah
right um so yeah essence of integrity
and resilience and self-reliance
absolutely
so um going back to like the kids and i
want to take through kind of how you
view the world as um as a leader
as a as a ceo of a lab and of a project
that we'll get to
as we continue but um i want to take you
on a little story that i participated in
last year i was in washington dc giving
a talk at the
national philosophical society which is
uh in the cosmos club in washington dc
i had a couple hours to kill and one of
my friends like oh
you know you've never been to the
holocaust museum why don't you go to the
national holocaust museum
you know what i've heard so many things
about the african-american museum of
history and culture
let me go there right and i have you
know perfect timing it's free
you know you can't beat it lines weren't
too bad beautiful it's beautiful
but you know i'm i'm down there i'm in
the basement
i'm bawling i'm like i see the slave
ships i see the
the passage right i see the you know
these people that you know white people
look like me
even though you know my relatives are in
eastern europe you know at the time
but um and and then you know so you're
going on this emotional roller coaster
downstairs it's really just brutal
gut-wrenching
uh then you go up and it's like um
there's there's musicians you get
everything you know
little richard up to you know beyonce
and then you know and the influence on
rock and roll and the blues
that's awesome and then you go up uh you
see you know beyonce and whatever and
then you get up and you see comedians
and you see
uh tuskegee airmen all these great
wonderful aspects of history and culture
but i'm like where's the science exhibit
where is it where is it in the africa
and i'm like what is that like if a
gentry nowadays a little eight-year-old
gentry goes there
or are your daughters what are they
gonna see is gonna inspire them to do
you know a different brand and i'm
speaking now not as you know black
versus white i'm just saying
science and culture as a part of culture
where do you view a science and your
science as a culture
part of the human culture and
civilization experience i think
you know you know as i mentioned stem is
all around us
it's what allows us to exist right and
our ability to engage it um but
i i think that um
you know we have to find a way
to partner like science can't be in a
vacuum and it's not in a vacuum as i
just mentioned but
science in the arts science and the
community um
i think as faculty as uh
institutions academic and both you know
uh for-profit nonprofit uh
institutions of science biotech what
have you
we all need to be figuring out ways
where we are communicating
our science to the world
and to our community specifically in our
own backyards right
um wherever you are you should be able
to
relay why what you do and this is a good
uh mark of a of a of a great
um speaker right when they can
deliver a message to anyone whether they
be
eight years old or 85
uh and suffering from some from
some mental lapse right you should be
able to
uh tell why you're interested in what
you do
to some degree what you do um and
what that means to the rest of the world
or else we're just doing it in a vacuum
right and so i do think that
for kids of color underserved we need
more
um showcase of
the amazing scientists and talent pool
from
that are black and brown scientists
across this country you know there's a
lot of
us it needs to be more but the ones that
exist
we need to also be able to step out of
our labs and
say yeah this is me and this is what i
tell their story
a lot of times it's the rat race right
you know
our community sometimes is built in a
way that
you're always chasing the next grant
you're always
um chasing the next paper you never have
a moment to just sit and
exist and be with it right you're always
you get scooped or else you get
threatened
and so i i
look for the day when science also
learns
where collaboration is just as important
i know
in my career i've had a lot of
collaborators
and it's been meaningful to my career
where i've either learned something else
or i've been a part of something that i
thought was important
as opposed to always pushing to be
better than the next person yeah right
that's not what drives me
i love the inquiry of science and doing
science
but i love being able to share that
story and we need to be more
storytellers
and so that people young people
from any background you know do you feel
like scientists have an obligation i
mean
you know you always hear this thing like
oh carl sagan or neil degrasse tyson
or bill nye you know bill not real son
but nevertheless
he's got some funny things online though
yeah he's very good at what he did
but do you think that we as scientists
have an obligation to you know
take acting classes i mean when you just
say like oh i'm just not gonna i'm gonna
stay in the lab
well the public's paying your salary you
know at some level through their taxes
or through their state
salary in our case as you see uh
professors do you feel like we have an
obligation
uh to up our game or at least spend some
amount of our time
uh devoting ourselves to outreach and
and improving ourselves in terms of
their absolute community if
absolutely if you're not if you are
getting funds
from you know the government nih nsf
and any other government
your findings to others and that passion
that you have
we should be impacting the world and
leaving something better so
yes um i do have a lot of colleagues who
want to do that but then there are some
who could care less yeah right
and you know i always say we're always
evolving
yeah there's an evolution that's been is
taking place and
in time and space right now that you're
seeing that right when you think about
what's happening with the social unrest
i think people are saying you know
enough is enough yeah um
and you can't you can't silo yourself
you mentioned earlier you brought a word
which i don't normally associate
um in this context with academia
although i do in other ways like fear of
missing out
uh fear of uh lack of credit attribution
you know
we don't make profits right what we do
but we get citations and things like
that
um you mentioned like fear as kind of
like you know like i heard jamie
um fox once said like like what's on the
other side of fear
nothing like what how do you approach
that notion
of you know handling a very primal
biological notion
rooted in the neurons you know you know
what is fear when i say fear what does
it mean to you and what do you mean by
it when you spoke about it earlier
uh quite simply fear
is a lack of empathy for yourself
that's what fear is interesting to me um
when i can have empathy and just realize
that i'm a human
i'm a father that i'm a professor that
i'm a mentor
that i am a son uh
that i'm a uh um a community member
um that i'm one to to do the right thing
in a moment when someone might be in
need
uh that
that empathy that allows me to exist in
that
um allows the fear of
the unknown to kind of just disappear
right
um we don't no one knows what's tomorrow
it's going to bring no one knows what
the next few hours will bring
um but i think when we surround
ourselves with
like-minded people that care about
similar things
um that care about a better future
and i know this may sound a little uh
i don't know the word would be but uh
kind of looking on the sunny side of
everything right um
pollyanna but yeah but to be to be
honest
that's what i want to live leave my two
daughters
you know i don't want them growing up
just angry and upset about
existing here right you know i want them
to realize
that they can take hold and and and have
a future
that they can make for themselves
and and and and exists with others yeah
very good so um you're about to hire
grad student there's two grad students
they're equally you know gpa gre i don't
even know if you guys have gre anymore
we're trying to do away with it but yeah
but you see one is like uh there's two
different types of chess grand masters
one is is like can think like 50 moves
ahead
and just like foresees the future kind
of like strategically
where he or she is going to get to go
and everyone's like more tactical more
broad might know
the philosophy you know like like
opening moves and just kind of like oh i
know in general i want to recruit these
tools
when you're looking at somebody to
potentially hire as an employee postdoc
or whatever lab are you looking for the
broad you know kind of like i understand
biology i understand neuroscience i
understand or do you want someone who's
a machine that can go
deep deep deep where no one else can go
before uh and you can't say both
you know because it's very both of those
traits right
the breath and yeah they choose one
right yeah so like what appeals to you
where do you see yourself are you a
generalist
are you the macro kind of person are you
more micro and you like to drill down
focus and nerd out on the most
microscopic details how do you
approach it and what do you look for in
an employee right so
i would say i like to find
the gaps where um
maybe two fields have not merged yet
so i do like detail but i'm i would
consider myself more of a generalist i'm
a cell biologist
who studies neurons and synapses and
receptors glutamate receptors and
they're trafficking
to and from the synapse um so you know
just happens to be a neurons but i could
be studying receptors in another cell
type but it i love
i learned to love the brain and now i'm
a you know full-fledged
neuroscientist doing this type of work
but um
for me the ability to be adaptable
is really important right you may so
i started using biochemistry and you
know to some degree
imaging and then moved on to being able
to use electrophysiology and
mouse models what have you i like
bringing lots of techniques together
to solve questions that may have been
actually
begun to be addressed in other fields or
in other places
and kind of usurping them and finding
that
overlap so that's what i did
as a as a graduate student leaving
graduate school going into my post-doc
um no one was working on protein
half-life control at the level that i
wanted to
look at um and uh i just brought two
ideas together
this i went into a lab that had never
worked on this and i said hey
you work on local protein synthesis
would you be interested in protein
degradation
and you're like yeah okay maybe i should
think about that right um
today that's a full field now right um
but i think for me the graduate student
uh i i would hope that
i'd have a mixture i'm sorry i'm gonna
have to do this a mixture of both
right okay and the reason is because
you you you want that graduate student
that can drill down
and be the level of rigor that actually
takes you to the unknown where people
may not have gone right
but also that uh breath
of being able to pull away pull back out
and say
hey you know what this may not be where
we need to be
we may need to move into this other
space right here and
adaptable and uh
definitely being able to deal with
failure because they're going to fail 90
of the time that 10 is what they're
going to be putting on their walls
right they're going to fail i got a
question for you um
so when i look back in my life i see
certain things that at this
at the time seemed catastrophic getting
fired from stanford university as a
freshly minted postdoc being you know
first and foremost
uh seemingly unrecoverable
but in my case it led to you know great
success in fact you know you and i
being here and you you know being
partners with my with my cousin right so
these things would not have happened
were it not for this failure that i
experienced or what i thought was a
failure
have you had experiences like that where
you you know stumbled something happened
you tripped
maybe you let yourself down maybe you
let somebody else down
and and then but in the end you wouldn't
be the gentry patrick the professor
at uc san diego without it potentially
i definitely had lots of power here um
and some of the things that
come to mind for me are those things
that
you know if i had not picked myself up
or
not reached out or not figured out
something
in that particular time we may not be
here
right we may not be filming this right
now
um my first year after
undergrad i did very poorly
and i did not set myself up well enough
to even have a place to stay so i
literally became homeless for a couple
weeks
right couch surfing getting vouchers
from
the county to stay in hotels uh
most people would not you know not guess
that that is something that i
experienced but
you know all of these types of
experiences actually
we're like putting one layer of thin
paint at a time and eventually you form
a brick
that i don't know how long that would be
but your foundation is there right
right your your foundation is there and
so i wouldn't change any of that but
that was definitely a time when
i didn't know that i could
get up every day when i couldn't see the
next move
um but then i learned to persist
right and persisting didn't mean banging
on the same door
sometimes it means it meant standing
back and
listening looking and trying to
integrate
where i am right now and where i might
want to go and that may be
novel experiences that you might you
know a problem that
that we deal with with regards to
underserved black and brown students
in stem a lot of times they don't trust
yeah the system
right and so um there's got there's got
to be a meeting somewhere
meeting other minds and and uh
for me you know being able to persist
was
really important
what about your research is has been
most fascinating
surprising maybe even influential
that you do that you would want to tell
the world about that's just
something that you contributed to the
corpus of human knowledge
and it's also incredibly fun and
passionate
and exciting so what's excited me most
in science is the aspect of
time and space what do i mean by my
language
what do i mean by that you know i'm a
cosmologist
what do i mean by that um i got
fascinated
by the fact that the central dogma which
dictates that
dna rna goes to proteins
proteins and rna don't live forever but
proteins do a large majority of the work
these proteins that um in the case of
the work that i do since i study protein
half-life control and protein
homeostasis
um uh proteins have to get to a place
where they function
and they're only there for a certain
period of time and i got fascinated by
the fact that
the half-life of the persistence
population of a protein
um basically half-life is uh the amount
of protein that's left
50 and how much time it takes to get to
that point
but uh when you think about a neuron
about
different cell types that have wildly
different structures a neuron has a cell
body in these processes dendrites and
axons
and then specialized contact points like
synapses both pre and postsynaptically
proteins have to get there they exist
for a period of time
and then they had turned over and i got
really excited about the rules
the the genetic rules that would be in
play
the activity and experience dependent
rules
like experience that that neuron has the
actual information that it
receives that controls the persistence
of those proteins
and from there i saw while that why that
was
so important even to not only synapse
function
and neuronal function but it was also
important for
um disease and disease
uh pathology
the progression of disease you may not
know but
um most diseases of the brain neurogenic
diseases
are diseases of altered protein
homeostasis something goes awry
the amount of protein that's being made
or the amount of protein that's being
degraded
sometimes you degrade proteins because
like in alzheimer's
you know you have toxic proteins build
up as in
also in huntington's disease and so
i got very interested in time and space
and actually
what we used to do and we still do to
this day is monitor proteins
in living cells and where they are how
they move and how long they persist
and so um and then you take that
and it's almost like an and gate where
you overlay the activity dependent rules
which control their persistence in those
places
we're still pushing on that front but
that to me
excites me because it's a level of cell
biology it's a level of just the central
dogma you know protein being made
because of
a sequence of events that you know in
some cases you might have a
transcription factor which
drives gene expression that might be out
in distal dendrites of a neuron
but it gets a signal traffic translocate
back to the cell body
into the nucleus activates some that
then goes back and tags that set of
specific synapses
it's all amazing that you know
six billion nucleotides
is dictating uh a variety of
specialized machines so when i teach
build one
i get excited about teaching about what
biology wants to sell
sorry um but i'm always talking about 3d
structure making sure that the kids
realize that
protein x is not just a word on a page
it is a leading
living thing that you can turn around
and look at
yeah and then for me to have that and
then also know that it has to get to
place x and it's only going to be there
for a certain period of time
yeah and so i have on the brevity of
life right
yeah yeah that's really amazing that's
that's now you got me geeky now yeah
now the inner gig is coming out i'm
gonna ask you some some pop questions
because again i don't have too many uh
too many deep thoughts in this in this
realm of the brain um
uh true or false you can take
supplements to prolong your cognitive
function prohibit your cognitive decline
and you can say pass if you're not i'm
going to pass it okay
what about training your brain
cross-training your brain can you do
crossword puzzles can you do
uh sudoku do you do any first of all do
you do a movie do you take any
supplements let me see this is not
medical advice
i i take vitamins yes yeah and what
about exercise because you're
very fit you love to hike you love to
fish
you have to do all those things but um
do you do stuff
that um notes between the you know
taking care of your physical body
improves your mental body your mental
body
um luckily uh your cousin and my partner
uh is helping me find
that connection to mindfulness okay so
mindfulness is really what's your
routine tell me tell me
where we live stressful lives you and i
of course yeah people say oh you know
you're ten years forget it
your real life is your worries are our
kids are always trying to
you know put lock us in a dungeon right
um and then you know between writing
grants and running programs
we do so many different things um
you have to be able to find that calm
and all of the sea of
chaos uh we exist we love the chaos yeah
right thrive right we thrive right in it
um
but i've learned that i need to be able
to
bring myself back down and find a place
of mindfulness
that allows me to i always try to go
high level but
sometimes either not high enough high
level enough with regards to
okay putting things in perspective but
also just knowing that we're human
physio our physiology is linked in many
cases to the stress
and the response that we're um
engaging and how we're engaging so
interesting you say that because i was
thinking back to what you said earlier
about fear and like self-love self-love
meditation mindless like self-care
i've had on some mindfulness experts
like dr judson brewer
md phd at brown university i've had on
people that are opposed to him like noam
chomsky
i'm like don't you have this voice that
never stops in your head going
and uh yeah and but to hear you say that
and connecting like
calming meditative thoughts are another
tool
to use against that foe which is fear
and academics we face so much fear
fear of rejection fear of not getting
promotion 10 you're not being cited
and people think it's just the easiest
you know three hour a week job in the
world it's
not it's not no definitely not yeah yeah
this is these are things so what we
haven't talked about is uh
the scholarship program i've built yeah
we're gonna talk about and um
but these are some of the things that we
implement there yeah because it's not
just about like
it's it's a meta skills networking
collaboration but
let's get into it let's talk about it so
uh you run this past program which you
started in your 2019
convocation speech at uc san diego which
is kind of like the
analog of a graduation speech but at the
beginning of the year yeah welcoming
everybody it's
so funny how few people know what a
convocation speech is but how many
people know what a graduation speech is
which i
assume you'll do many of those if you
haven't already but in your convocation
speech you speak about these these three
different themes
and you talk about you know kind of the
access the mentorship the collaboration
the paths program first of all is
co-sponsored sponsored in part
ucsd chan zuckerberg uh initiative right
talk about that how did you not only uh
so we
we started the beginning of the podcast
talking a little bit about your vision
and your mission
in life i see this as like a part of
being a salesmanship or saleswoman you
know
you have to do this as a scientist it's
not enough that you think you're
brilliant
or you have some great idea it's never
going to scale it's never going to get
out into the world right how do you
convince people to to buy into your
vision
not only with their hearts because
you're a very inspirational person you
know that
um and and people really feel a
force of gravity towards you um and i'm
a physicist so i can say that
uh but on the other hand it's not enough
because you have to get people to open
their wallets
and how do you how did you do that how
does it work with okay chan
and chan zuckerberg is priscilla chan
mark zuckerberg right
uh founders of facebook and uh chan
zuckerberg initiative doctor
right right right so to be honest
it all started really with people buying
into my story
and me selling them that i can make new
stories out there
and give me a kid and i can help build
that story
right uh i've had donors
who told me straight out gentry we're
supporting you and your vision we hope
you do it
we hope you don't fail we hope you
impact the lives of these young people
but we're buying into you so i've
evaluated my life in such a way and
found
the nuances the salient important
impactful things
i said what did it take for me to be
successful
and that's why it comes down to access
mentorship and advocacy
and that's where i said i want to build
a
scholarship program that puts all of
that in there
at an uber level that allows for these
kids to
really thrive um
and that's what it's doing we're in our
third cohort right now and
how many kids go through it we've taken
we took the first two years uh 12 a year
and
now we took 15. interestingly enough you
know
it's really gaining traction right so we
had
50 70 applicants first couple years
this past year we had over 500
applications for 15 spots
i did not realize that right and these
are some of the most impressive i was uh
honored to be president
first speakers and then yeah yeah yeah
first
but let me come back to what you said so
the the students are doing absolutely
great and i'll give you some of the
details of what's in the program yeah
we'll put links in the notes and
everything too
what's what is it that allows someone to
see
that they can partner with me why would
a venture philanthropist say
i see i see it and you say well ginger
he's inspirational
little no i didn't tell you this uh my
father and all
of his brothers uh
were and are ministers yeah right
so speaking in front of large crowds
that's we're good with that that's one
thing you have the word of god you know
it's your material
and it's up to the delivery yeah exactly
i think i knew that about your dad i
didn't know that about you
yeah exactly okay no my uncle has a big
church like
almost like a little a mega church in
houston yeah
um so uh i think
i lean in with such transparency and
i crystallized what exactly needs to
happen i'm like
there are many non-profits there are
many programs
and they all kind of silo themselves
they don't all cycle let me reframe that
they can be siloed and so
i knew that the genius or the innovation
would be
to if you're going to create another
scholarship program there's just many
all over the right you need to do
something
that doesn't facilitate siloing of your
scholars
the program and actually thrives
and is driven by true partnership
um really this came about pathways to
stem to enhance
access and mentorship otherwise known as
the path scholars program
um really came about because um
and i'll get into some of the details of
what it does it came about because
of my commitment to science and you may
say what does it mean
what do you mean by that the fact
that i had a platform
i was a leader in my field
um you know as a team tenured professor
now a full professor
uh with advancement you know now
um uh and the fact that i
had just bought into this idea of
science is my community giving talks
all over the place every year and at
meetings like gordon conference and
passive meetings
even if i was the only black person
right i was there and i knew in many
cases i was like i better
give a good talk right right that's
another form of attacks right right
right
outperform um when it was time to like
do something like this
people didn't say oh yeah he has a great
idea they were like
he clearly has connected you know if he
was able to
trans go on a trajectory from
starting in inner city south central la
compton california
going through all that what he did and
if he wants to
pull out those salient parts of what
helped him be successful
i'll buy into that right and you know
obviously i can communicate that well to
them
um but that's how it started i really i
went to
uh with regards to chan zuckerberg uh
corey bargman who i think she was voted
like
most influential or most important
scientists of in some year a couple
years ago
i think right when she became the czi
president of science of science corey
bargmann um
she's known me since i my days at ucsf
and she's followed my career and in some
cases she's been there to advocate and
mentor me
um and uh i said hey
i'm gonna start this new program she
said hold on we were just talking with
uh dr freeman harbowski who's the
president of the university of maryland
baltimore county
who's now a friend and i look up to him
very much so he's a passionate
speaker and author you should definitely
get him on your uh
convocation right uh
so no he was not at the convocation
freeman is the
the president of umbc and started the
meyerhop scholarship am i right yeah
yeah i thought he was he didn't come out
oh okay he's come out once yeah
he's like gentry you guys work on it for
five years and then i'll come
we'll get out here in january yeah you
know baltimore is nice in the winter
right right right
now it's gonna be and so again
serendipity of course
because that's how my life works but
because i had a science footprint
and a good one i was able to leverage
that
to talk about how we can do more and
people were like okay
i like this let's let's and then you get
other people involved and so what's
great about
this partnership is is it it's between
berkeley and ucsd
as well as umbc and chan zuckerberg
initiative is funding all three
to basically model what meyerhoff had
done
they are phenomenal in what they've done
and i've learned so much from
33 years now i believe um
[Music]
for instance the surgeon general is a
meyerhoff scholar
they basically make a community and this
is what i was talking about
you know you have these scholars that
come from these places where they
you know they show up on ucsd and it's
quite different than their home
right in their community and they don't
see you know they're not normally around
people with opulent wealth
or what have you and so it's they're
thrown out of
out of a cup into this context where
they have to persist
and not have impostor syndrome
and you know homosexual syndrome never
really goes away when you really think
of
a form of fear right yeah it's a form of
fear um and
they have to persist and so uh and
trust the system and so this is some of
the things that we really want to do
in our um we model after this program
and uh it's allowed us to be very
successful
um we lean in with the transparency and
allow our students to really
allow us to go along ahead on their path
and clear the way there's accountability
a great amount of accountability
community service there's graduate
advocates we have a
full staff three pro staff full-time
people who run the program
we have what's called graduate advocates
who help take care of not only
checking in with the students weekly but
they're talking
they're you know mindfulness how are you
doing how's your health how's your
mental health self-care
uh they're networking for them too
networking
meeting faculty like yourself uh and
it's been great
you can get a faculty member over lunch
we'll talk about themselves for an hour
yeah
that's that's like being assigned an
opening act for me man
only an hour right right and so um
this program is it's really been
special to see involved i've been
fortunate to have
you know major funding come through i
think it's helping them
it's a model program so it's helping the
campus to evolve and grow because
especially when you think about the time
that we're in right now we have to
really consider what are the best ways
that we can do this
and how are the partnerships driving
uh a better outcome for our black and
brown students
um that are coming from these
environments that are
here on campus and dealing with quite
frankly in many cases
uh uh racism and microaggressions
uh and not being able to deal with that
or
in some cases understand it yeah but how
do we
own our own community so that we can say
you know what
we can do better and that starts with
leadership that starts with
valuing uh the faculty that we have that
starts with
bringing more students and
through the pipeline right and
supporting them it starts with
in innovative ideas to to build within
divisions
hubs and success centers that will allow
i think
physical science has a success center
now right in biology we're about to do
something very similar
um uh with our with our own secret sauce
yeah
just to say throw down division versus
division
right um so again you know adam bomb you
guys have the bio weapon
yes exactly see how it works so
i'm really hopeful someone asked me you
know
do you have hope for the future i mean i
mean you could say all this fear
depending on
what happens in the near and short term
or
long term but i think i think um
when we own our own existence and our
own community
and we have empathy for the people
around us we can do something
very special um and that's whether
you're a astrophysicist cosmologist
uh whether you're a doctor whether
you're a neuroscientist
whether you're a kid from compton
california um
who and by the way
um i loved it i love you know being here
at ucsd
i do know that um
one day the things that i do here serve
as a model to
impact that world i want to be able to
go back to compton one day and start
something special and partner with great
people whether it be in the
entertainment
you know industry as well as science and
there's a lot of innovation to be had to
really do something special in that
community i can't wait to do that
wow there's nobody better suited than
you my friend i cannot wait to see where
you go next on the pathway
to greatness not only for yourself but
for all these students that you serve i
just want to thank you
so grateful uh not only to be a friend
but to have you as a colleague you're
really a treasure
and i want to thank you for spending
time with the into the impossible
podcast thank you very much thank you
for having me
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric virey director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco